hey everyone i'm lucy and i love mass
effect
now as you can imagine i'm very excited
about the legendary edition that's
coming up
but it's not going to be out for a few
weeks so in order to get my fix
i've actually gone back to playing
andromeda and i've been re-watching the
trailer for the brand new mass effect
and as someone who has loved and played
the games i
am really excited about the franchise's
future and i was thinking about what the
brand new game
could take from the old games as well as
the changes that i would love to see
bioware make so that's why i'm making
this video yes it's an excuse to talk
about mass effect
but i love it so that's why we're making
this video
if you're excited about mass effect 2
then please subscribe we've got so much
more in the pipeline
in the run-up to the legendary edition
and beyond you're not going to want to
miss it
anyway that's a long preamble let's get
into what we want to see
in the brand new mass effect we know
that the next mass effect is a sequel of
sorts in the trailer we get to see two
galaxies one of which is the milky way
the other one is probably the
andromeda galaxy we see an older liara
walking along the dead body of a reaper
now that one was confirmed by bioware
and of course she picks up something
with n7 on it
beyond just emails from liara and easter
eggs andromeda was pretty tightly
connected to mass effect
trilogy uh spoilers for the ending of
andromeda
but i don't know your mileage may vary
on how big of a spoiler this
is it's something that you kind of had
to dig for but
the true purpose of the andromeda
initiative was to save milky way
civilizations from
the reapers by sending them millions of
light years away
so that they would hopefully never be
found it's been theorized
that the initiative was actually
secretly funded by the elusive man
which has never really quite sat right
with me because i don't understand why
he
who is always a humanity first would put
money and resources into saving all of
the civilizations but i
digress and that was just an example of
just one of the threads that andromeda
left hanging
you know we don't really understand what
happened to the quarian arc beyond what
was written about in
a spin-off book and not the dlc we don't
understand why the quet
and the reapers are actually quite
similar in the way that they like to
assimilate and harvest other
civilizations
who was the benefactor who was the
murderer there's a lot of this stuff
left hanging
and so with the dead reaper and liara's
more aged appearance
it's pretty clear that this game is
going to be taking place after the
events
of the original trilogy so what i want
to know is what happened to the milky
way beyond what we saw in the extended
cut endings
and most importantly is bioware going to
be making any of the endings
canon from the looks of things with a
dead reaper and a destroyed mass effect
relay it looks like they might be making
destroy cannon but
who knows maybe that was just for this
trailer so i want to know what happened
in the milky way after the events of the
trilogy
and i want those loose threads from
andromeda tied up so the new mass effect
i really hope
takes the two eras of mass effect and
just
i don't know brings them together
but saying that i think commander
shepard's time is
done their arc was fantastic but to me
it is
finished i know that liara's there and
she's picking up a piece of
n7 armor which everyone's thinking like
oh maybe they're bringing commander
shepard back and it's gonna be lazarus
project 2.0
but i actually kind of really hope that
they don't do that i want to see a new
mass effect
through a new character's eyes maybe the
new character is someone who isn't even
a specter
maybe it's someone who doesn't have the
weight of the galaxy and the hopes of
millions
on their shoulders maybe it's someone
who's not even human that would be
super cool one thing i genuinely hope
the bioware doesn't do
is bring commander shepard back but have
them as a side character
now they did that with hawke in dragon
age inquisition so hawk was a playable
character in dragon age 2.
and it just felt really weird to have
hawk there alongside you and listening
to their voice and
not be the person controlling them i
spent dozens of hours with my hawk and
it just felt very strange to me so i
don't want that to happen with commander
shepard
and from a narrative standpoint i don't
even understand how bioware would import
shepherds
in think about your time with the
trilogy
that's hundreds of little decisions and
dialogue options
they're all nuanced and so i don't
understand how bioware could do that
uh to account for everyone's experience
unless they just
wiped the slate clean or brought over
the big decisions
but if you're gonna do that then why
bother bringing shepard at all i've seen
a few people say that they might like to
play as liara but
i can see her having the same issues
narratively too so
maybe just start fresh with a brand new
character
all the hubbub and excitement around the
legendary edition has led to this
resurgence in
interest in older mass effect games and
how they were made
and one such piece over at the gamer by
keon ma talks about the cut races that
were supposed to be
in mass effect andromeda it's actually
quite a heartbreaking piece because it
turns out that bioware were only given
the budget
for two new races and you could argue
that they were actually pretty similar
one of my favorite parts of the original
trilogy was those alien races
and just how well bioware introduced
them made references to their past and
status
and their general disdain of humans why
do you bother
kailyn these earth clan don't really
care about our ways
remorseful response den you don't truly
believe that
and if you do i am very sorry for you
i loved learning about their history and
their customs
and each race looked felt and sounded
distinct by the time you get to the
citadel in mass effect 1 and you see
them all interacting with each other
it feels like the melting pot of the
galaxy that it's supposed to be
which is why andromeda was such a
disappointment to me in that regard
because
you crash land in this brand new galaxy
and the first new exciting alien species
you meet
the first thing you do is shoot them
well the first thing they did was shoot
you
but whatever the angara were cool but
the fact that there were a bunch of
races missing for narrative reasons like
the quarian and the drill meant that
andromeda just didn't feel
as populated i know the quarian arc
stuff was meant to be for dlc that never
materialized but still
it was a disappointment and that's why i
really really hope that in a new mass
effect
we'll get to see more alien races
if we're talking about combat throughout
the games each has its highs and lows
there's a lot to be said about mass
effect 1's combat it was pretty clunky
but it did have those deep rpg routes
which i loved mass effect 2 was more of
a mix between action and rpg
you could easily issue commands to your
squad but general movement didn't feel
as smooth as it could have
mass effect 3 is fast frenetic every
class can use every weapon
and there's more of an emphasis on
combos it's probably my favorite of the
lot
andromeda felt a bit floaty to me and as
someone who was more of a methodical
player
being unable to control my squadmates
power usage and stuff
just wasn't it for me i didn't really
enjoy that i like having control
i would genuinely love to see mass
effect take a more dragon age approach
and let you directly control assuming
direct control
of your squad mates during fights i also
think that like
if you make the classes feel a bit more
distinct that would be really cool
because otherwise
you know you might pick a class that you
think sounds interesting but you're not
really enjoying after 20 hours or so i
know you can respec and everything but
that would really give it an element of
fun on the fly
switching and experimentation
i'd be interested to know how you all
feel about the more open world aspects
of mass effect andromeda because
upon replaying the game i've just found
out that i don't i don't particularly
enjoy it
and actually thinking back i don't think
i enjoyed the more open-world
parts of the original mass effect either
and it's not because i hate piloting the
mako i am a mako apologist
i don't mind that clunky old thing but
when you compare one to two and three
where the level design was way much more
straightforward
it's night and day because i'm not just
driving around looking at a compass at
the top of my screen like i am in
andromeda
hoping to find something interesting so
i'm not saying that i wouldn't like to
see an open world mass effect i
genuinely think that could be really
interesting if it was something
the scale of red dead 2 or skyrim
i just think that if you're gonna make a
mass effect game that's open world
it has to be packed with stuff that
justifies that size
so i'm not talking about dragon age
inquisition where i'm
you know collecting shards around the
hinterlands i can't do that
again if you're gonna make these levels
big and huge
there has to be stuff in there to
justify it
i can't collect shards again please
don't make me
this is an obvious one but it's a topic
that's definitely worth bringing up when
it comes to
mass effect javik being day one dlc
sucked he was an integral part of that
game
he should never have been carved out and
sold separately he should have just been
in it andromeda's case with quarian arc
is
similar but different obviously they
left that thread dangling because they
thought it was going to be in dlc and it
would be resolved that way
but that dlc was cancelled and that
storyline was kind of resolved
in a book sort of what i'm saying is
please you know keep dlc i'm not saying
get rid of dlc i'm saying please don't
take things
from the main storyline and carve them
out
to be dlc because we the players feel
that as we're playing
like it's it's obvious and it just leads
to resentment honestly
and so i really don't want to see that
in the new mass effect
uh i i mean you can talk about things
like layer of the shadow broker and
citadel but i would argue that those
cases are very different because
they're not integral to the main
storyline of mass effect 2 and mass
effect 3.
they are nice little side stories whose
outcomes don't feed into
the main ending right they're just more
opportunities to get to know squad mates
a little bit better so like i said keep
dlc
i enjoy dlc it means that i can revisit
a game that i loved and play it longer
and
experience more stories in that world
but if you can make dlc please just
don't take it from the main story
and sell it to me separately
paragon and renegade need a bit of a
rework and i guess technically speaking
they would actually need
a re-introduction because they weren't
in andromeda
i digress when you look back at the
original trilogy some of the dialogue
options would result in
pretty out-of-line responses
and i think one thing that it didn't
really take into consideration was that
not every decision or dialogue choice
was black or white you know sometimes
you want to get into a nice little gray
area
and speaking from experience when i
first played mass effect 1
i didn't commit fully either way and i
lost rex on vermeyer because of that and
i still feel guilty
and i just really would have loved that
wiggle room to hopefully try and save my
squad mate
andromeda's response to this was to
remove paragon and renegade completely
and instead what you would do
is you would sort of change the tone of
the conversation which i actually
really liked i thought that was very
cool but i also like having an
overarching system that's kind of
tallying up my morality
and then that directly affects dialogue
options and choices that i can make
later on in the game
so i would love to see some kind of mesh
between the two
i think that would be really cool and
would work and i'm definitely not saying
please bring back the glowing scars
from mass effect 2. um i just i just you
know
i want people to know that i'm a badass
or a really great nice
person you know all right i've talked
about mass effect for long enough
my throat hurts i'm gonna be stopping
but if you like mass effect
then we have a bunch of stuff right here
on the channel we have an interview
with mac walters about the cut
characters from mass effect 2.
we have a granular breakdown of the
changes coming to the legendary edition
uh john luke made a really cool side by
side of scenes from the original trilogy
and the legendary edition so if you're
interested in all that make sure to like
this video and subscribe
and let me know what you think of the
things that i pointed out today what are
your feelings about a brand new mass
effect let me know
i'm gonna be all up in those comments
because you know me i love talking about
mass effect
i'm on twitter if you want to hang out
with me there i'm over at lucy james
games
i'll see you next time
[Music]
you